اذا البرتغال اليوم تقص شريط ابو مشاركتها
في كاس عالم 2022 امام المنتخب الغاني
مباراه طبعا الحديث فيها كله يتمحور حول
لاعب واحد هو كريستيانو رونالدو رونالدو
الذي اصبح في ارجنت اليوم يعني بلا نادي
ويبحث عن نادي في الموسم المقبل او في
النصف الثاني من الموسم عفوا لذلك رونالدو
الان هو محور الاهتمام شو اللي راح يقدمه
رونالدو كيف رح يكون مستواه بالمباراه
امام غانا هل راح يتخلص من الضغوطات اللي
عاشها على مدار اشهر على مدار اسابيع
الاخيره هل راح يتخلص المنتخب البرتغالي
كله من ازمه كرستيانو رونالدو
وتاثيراتها وتداعياتها على منتخب البرتغال
وخصوصا اللاعبين مثل برونو فرنانديز الذين
كانوا بقلب العاصفه اخيرا بسبب الفيديو
اللي انتشر مؤخرا علامات استفهام كبيره
حول الاداء المنتخب البرتغالي راح تكون
بهذه المباراه حول اداء رونالدو حول
انسجامه مع المجموعه حول دور برونو
فرناندوس ايضا داخل ارضيه الملعب بصراحه
منتخب غانا مش منتخب سهل
منتخب عنده اسماء كبيره جدا عنده نياكه
ويليامز لاعب اتلتيكو بلباو عنده طارق
لامتي لاعب نادي برايتر بالدوري الانجليزي
عنده توماس بارتي ايضا لاعب ارسنال وغيره
مثل اندري ايو وجوردن ايو وغيرهم من
اللاعبين المميزين جدا منتخب ابي يطمح
لانه يحقق اول انتصار للقاره الافريقيه في
كاس العالم 2022 بعد تقريبا خساره وتعاد
وتعادل كل المنتخبات الافريقيه الاخرى
لذلك غانا اليوم راح تدخل بحافز كبير راح
تدخل برغبه كبيره راح تدخل بدافع لتحقيق
نتيجه ايجابيه امام البرتغال وخلق
المفاجاه بعض المفاجئته الارجنتين
والسعوديه الشخصي واليابان والمانيا ايضا
براي شخصي من مباراه اليوم راح تكون همم
تجربه المنتخب البرتغالي اختبار للمنتخب
البرتغالي لمعرفه هل سيذهب بعيدا في هذا
المونديال ولا راح يغادر مبكرا هذا امر
متروك بعلم الغيب ولكن على ارض الواقع
اعتقد انه المنتخب البرتغال لازم يحاول
قدر الامك سيطر على الكره ويسجل هدف مبكر
لكسب الثقه في ظل هذه الظروف النفسيه
والدهنيه الصعبه جدا التي يمر بها منتخب
البرتغال بسبب ازمه كريستيانو رونالدو
الاخيره مع مانشستر يونايتد خلينا نشوف شو
راح يصير بالمباراه وراح نكون معكم بعض
المباراه بتحليل واضح لما حدث في مونديال
تشيك فانتظرونا